if you're planning on getting behind the
wheel be prepared for traffic as you can
see here near State Line Mary Jane
beliesza joining us live with what to
expect for the road trip
good evening Kirsten and Brian I'm here
on the I-15 off of Rancho near Sahara
and as you can see behind me on the I-15
this is moving southbound it's not too
bad traffic is moving rather smoothly
and whether you're driving into or out
of town anticipate traffic and delays as
millions of Travelers are on the road
this Thanksgiving
AAA predicts this year to be the third
busiest for Thanksgiving travel since
AAA started tracking numbers in the
early 2000s spokesman John Traynor says
many Travelers are driving to their
destinations much like last year we
wondered what were gas prices going to
do what was the price of everything
going on going to do The Travelers but
it doesn't seem to have affected the
appetite for travel and I think that
speaks to the power of the holiday we
haven't been able to do this a lot
pandemic restrictions have made it
either difficult or impossible for some
people to go home and see family they
don't have to do that anymore Las Vegas
is a top destination spot with many
tourists coming in from neighboring
states like Anisha 5 from Orange County
California he drove to Las Vegas Sunday
night to Beat the Traffic he and his
family are doing some sightseeing before
they plan to go back to California
tomorrow we're gonna leave tomorrow
which is early in the morning so to
avoid the traffic because I have two
kids
yeah okay beautiful my brother and my
wife too so so much fun we've never been
here it's so exciting we've been in a
lot of places Las Vegas is the best
Andres and Laura Lopez arrived last
night from Los Angeles California he
says drivers should be prepared for
congestion we just pick a car and we
drove all the way from LA to Las Vegas
and it took us about like six hours and
a half so the traffic was horrible there
was one one part of the of the freeway
was shot all the lanes were shot only
one opened and all the heavy traffic was
just crossing to one lane
AAA says the day before Thanksgiving is
the busiest day for road travel Sunday
is also expected to be busy if you're
heading back to Southern California on
Sunday know that it does get backed up
for miles near Prim so the best advice
try to leave early if you can or much
later live from the strip Mary Jane
beliesa 8 News Now